how do you prepare for a production day
when you're wearing so many hats you're
the producer director lead actor and
cinematographer the only thing I prepare
is getting everybody there
right there's no shot list there's
nothing I own all the equipment I own
all the gear I know how to work it I
know how to operate it I know what I'm
trying to capture in the lens because
the only thing I'm concerned about is
what's seen within that frame
so if I can get everyone there
I can move mountains
so the way I break it down is it's three
stages when you think about
filming and then final product
pre-production creating it words lining
everything up getting everyone ready
production the fun part everyone gets to
create have a good time you get to shoot
all that stuff post-production
you do all the the the color grading
editing ADR sound design music score
everything and then you have the fourth
phase which is selling distribution all
of that stuff and getting it out to the
world marketing
so when it comes to shooting on set
I break things down in a very easy
strategic way that's not only efficient
but it takes the pressure off of the
actors and actresses
it allows for the freedom of creativity
and it's easier on myself and my brother
so when I'm in front of the camera
I'll set up the shot set up the light
put at the focal length that I want
and then I'll hand it out to my brother
and my brother will go and I'm like okay
here move the camera here do this and
then he'll go in and do that stuff so
he's been a tremendous help in allowing
me to be in front of the camera and
still capture what I need to capture
by breaking it down into segments and
instead of taking this whole page as
this one scene you take a whole page and
break it down into four segments right
now it's like hey
as an actor you only have to worry about
these three lines right now this is what
we're gonna shoot
and instead of them having to do nine
lines they did three lines okay now
we're going to cut to this because I
shoot as an editor
that saves me so much time and space
because I don't get anything that I
don't need
the moment we get to take I know that's
the take I'm going to use to edit I move
on
I adjust the lights where I need it to
be and then we shoot in sequence so even
when I edit I know that the sequence is
going in line with the scene so if I'm
shooting line 27
we start at the beginning of 27.
and we shoot that in sequence then as we
shoot that and we get you know closer to
me being on camera because I tend to
shoot everyone else first
I get all their shots first and then I
shoot my sequence my sequences are a lot
quicker because I already kind of know
what I want to do with the character and
I my shots are less magical because
they're a lot more mechanical
here's the thing
I'm not the best actor right I would say
I'm probably like an average actor if
across the board I'm just average don't
I can do everything except Cry On Cue
like I've tried cutting onions I've
tried sticks I just can't cry I don't
know what it is I just can't cry but I
can do everything else
so when it comes to me being on camera I
know what looks good I know it sounds
good I know that if we're shooting close
up don't move your head too much you
know if you're gonna do action shots
we're gonna go a little wider
I get that so once I shoot everybody
else first and we've captured all of
their sauce because I'm so
um
aware of their time
that when it comes to me I do my takes
in about one or two takes and then we
move on
and I know that
now that I've said this on camera you
might be able to tell that oh okay he
did that like I wanted to takes because
we have to keep moving we have to keep
going and when you wear so many hats you
have to get out of your head that this
is stressful
did not like you're making a movie
you're setting people up you're setting
the lighting and you're pushing record
if this is what you want to do with your
life then it's fun time
so take away the stress because you are
what you think
so if you think making a movie is going
to be hard it's going to be hard but I
can tell you it's not hard it's time
consuming anything in life it's not hard
you're not out there drilling oil in the
middle of the ocean you're making a
movie
so if you can break it down into steps
and just be consistent filmmaking will
be a lot easier than you think it is
Hollywood likes to to give you the magic
and show you there's a hundred people on
set and that it's super difficult like
yeah to make
Hollywood's budget films Hollywood level
films you have Masters at each section
Masters at lighting Masters at
cinematography Focus polling directors
you have these Masters so they're coming
out with the master product
you as an indie filmmaker you don't have
those Masters
on your team a lot of the times so you
have to wear a lot of hats you have to
become the master
what that does is you trim the fat you
know how to streamline your movement and
you learn how to get things done but if
you learn how to direct and edit at the
same time your editing becomes so much
easier and it becomes
a lot more feasible and consumable to
digest the entirety of a film you edit
your films as well yes okay so I edit my
films uh a lot of times as I'm shooting
um with pizza boy Rick I wanted to do it
a little different so I'm shooting first
and then I I'm starting the editing
process I like to try different things
to kind of see what works for me but
when it comes to editing there's
two things that I really that I focus on
as I'm editing uh you're scrubbing
through the footage you're seeing what
you want you're kind of going for a
particular look so that's your color
grade from scratch
and it doesn't have to be anything fancy
you don't need 10 layers you you can
color it to get it to look good and then
decide if you want to go a little warm a
little cool you want to just keep it
neutral different scenes can kind of
look differently depending on where
you're at
the biggest thing about post-production
and editing is sound design like I can't
stress enough how important sound is
because
when I say you feel sound it's so true
when I say okay look we're going to edit
I'm going to take these 10 takes and I'm
going to edit it into the most dynamic
scene that I possibly can edit and
there's a lot of times where I see a
scene and I'm like man I wish I would
have did that differently because I only
give myself so many takes and because
you wear so many hats you don't have the
luxury of really thinking oh I'm gonna
do this with this character no because
it's like all right I'm directing okay
get in this goodness okay my turn action
then you go so when I am editing there's
a lot of times where as a actor right
taking off the other hats as an actor
I would have performed it maybe a little
different I would have let myself get
into that zone just a little bit more
but as a filmmaker
I'm like it's fine let's move on so
because I'm able to see that take and
I'm able to see it in the final timeline
on how I'm going to edit it what the
color grade is going to look like how is
it going to turn out what is it going to
sound like
the editing process
becomes the most enjoyable part about
the film because that's where it really
comes to life comes alive if you think
about any film that you love that's just
incredible to you
there's probably one or two things I'm
gonna say two things that I can
guarantee exists with any film that
anyone loves
sound design
music
and the reason why that's so important
is because they give you a Feeling
to a specific time and place
like I love 80s 90s music scores that's
what I love because that's what I grew
up with and for me those are kind of
Timeless scores right when you're
talking music
if
you're someone newer
you might like the early 2000s
scores because those were part of you at
a certain time in life right so
if you think about like I don't listen
to music that much anymore as I've
gotten older
all of the music that I listen to almost
stopped when I was like 2019 but that's
because in those times a lot of the
music is associated with things that
I've experienced for the first time
so then as you get older and you don't
experience things for the first time
anymore it doesn't have that same memory
impact
so
as a filmmaker
when you're in post-production or you're
thinking about how you want a shot to be
completed think of your sound think of
how you're going to do your sound design
so in my films a lot of times there's
not empty spaces where there's this
dialogue and the reason for that is
because I enjoy sound so much I want it
to be
almost like its own experience
throughout the story that if you could
turn off the dialogue and just hear the
sonic waves going without them talking
you can still get a sense of what's
happening in the film
so that's why sound design is so
important when you're in post-production
and shooting and editing at the same
time is extremely important as a
filmmaker especially if you're in front
of the camera
um
because it allows you to know exactly
what you're trying to capture and you
don't have to guess and then you don't
have to go through terabytes of footage
to try and just get that perfect shot
do you ever wish though like when you
get it in the editing Bay or excuse me
on the timeline like I wish I had one
more take of this all the time oh okay
all the time especially like
when you have Dynamic shots
um car shots
me in front of the camera
I always know especially in hindsight
right because when you're editing it's
almost hindsight like you've already
shot it so now you're editing
I always
as a creator
know that I can do it better
the moment it's done I know I can do it
better the moment where I'm like art
it's a wrap I know I can make that movie
better because I just gained all of that
experience points I just leveled up I
just became better because I just did
another project
um so there's certain things that you
see when you're editing that you don't
necessarily see on set because you're
thinking of five steps ahead or even
when you look at the shot you're like
yeah it looks great and then when you
look at it on a big screen you're like
uh that could have been focused a little
better or this person I didn't see that
soda can back there right you miss those
things sometimes
um but it's just it's it's all part of
the the
evolution of you as an artist it's all
part of
what you do when you make films you're
always going to look at something and
say I could have done that better